REGINA MANZANA-SAWHNEY:
Welcome, everyone.
Thank you for sharing
your afternoon with us.
I have many favorite
things about working here,
but one of my most favorites
is having the opportunity
to invite people I
admire, such as Chitra,
to Google to share her work.
Her stories have a magical
way of just immersing you
in the content.
When you're reading through,
you can literally see, feel,
and taste the experiences.
So thank you for bringing
your work back to Google
and introducing this book.
Her short story collection
"Arranged Marriage"
won an American
Book Award in 1995.
And two of her novels, which I'm
sure many of you are familiar
with-- "The Mistress of Spices"
and "Sister of My Heart"--
were adapted into the movies.
Today, she joins us to
introduce her new novel,
"Before we Visit
the Goddess," where
she'll talk about what
makes a woman successful,
and is this something
that changes over time?
She's an author, poet,
activist, and teacher,
and in 2015, she was chosen
by the "Economic Times"
as one of the 20 most
influential global Indian
women.
So thank you for joining
us today, Chitra.
[APPLAUSE]
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: It is
absolutely my pleasure, Regina.
Thank you for inviting me to
speak once again at authors
at Google.
So it's always a great
pleasure to come to Google.
And I have to start
off my talk by saying
how much easier Google has
made my life as an author.
First of all, the
search engine-- truly,
I think my books would
take twice as long
to write if I couldn't
research quickly
using the search engine.
So thanks to everyone
who's involved with that.
And the second thing is author--
I have to go to many places,
often in different cities.
And I have to drive to locations
that I don't know at all.
So all the Google map devices,
they have changed my life.
They have reduced
my anxiety level
because I'm kind of
an anxious traveler.
But they really reduced
my anxiety level
and made it possible.
So again, thanks to everyone
who's involved with that.
It is my great pleasure
today to come and present
to you my newest novel,
"Before we Visit the Goddess."
I'm very excited
about this novel
because it's about
something I've been
thinking about for a long time.
It is an intergenerational saga.
It is the story of a
grandmother, a mother,
and a daughter.
So it is about three
generations of women's lives
that crosses continents.
The grandmother, Sabitri,
lives all her life in India.
She's from the Kolkata area.
She's born in a
village, but then she
lives much of her
life in Kolkata.
Her daughter, Sabitri,
comes to the United States,
but under strange and
difficult conditions,
and can therefore no longer
go back to India after that.
So she spends her
life in America,
but she kind of spans the two
continents, both geographically
and culturally.
And then her daughter, Tara,
is born in the United States
and never goes back to India
and never sees her grandmother,
not face-to-face.
But she will connect
to her grandmother
in some interesting ways.
So this is a novel
about what do we pass on
to our future generations?
And I now have children
who are-- two boys who
are in their 20s, early 20s.
My own mother has
passed away now.
But I think of her often.
So I'm very interested in that,
that kind of river of influence
that comes down the generations.
And I'm sure all of us who
are parents or thinking
of being parents or have other
people in younger generations--
like maybe nephews or nieces--
we're all concerned about what
we are passing on to them.
This becomes especially
resonant if we
come from another
culture, and we
are living in a
different country,
because we want to make
sure we still passing
on important things
to them, and yet maybe
not in exactly the form
in which we received them.
We want to make the
heritage that we
give them appropriate
to their environment.
So that's a question that
all three of these women
think about-- and, in
fact, four generations,
because Sabitri's mother
passes on some important things
to her, as well.
So heritage and
mothers and daughters,
especially, are things that I'm
thinking about in this book,
but also, another question
that has been important to me
for a long time.
Now, my own mother--
when I was growing up,
when I was a teenager, my
mother was a single parent.
And for a number of years,
she struggled to bring up
my brothers and myself.
And she often told me,
I want to make sure
that when you grow up, you
don't have difficulties
taking care of the
people in your life that
are special to you.
I want you to be an
independent woman.
I want you to be a
successful woman.
And I've always
thought about that,
and I've taken that, kind
of, as my own mantra.
But I'm not sure
that what she meant
as a successful woman is what
I mean as a successful woman.
So the question the book
asks for the characters,
as well as for all of the
readers and for myself
as author, is what
does that mean?
What does it mean to
be a successful woman?
Is that something that
changes from era to era,
from country to country?
And even in our lives,
when we are younger,
does success means something?
When we are older,
what does success mean?
Is success something
we judge externally?
Is it something we feel
deep in our hearts?
So these are some of the things
that are special in this book.
With this book, I wanted
to set myself a challenge.
With each book, I like setting
myself a different challenge.
And I was talking to some
of you in the audience,
and you were telling me
about different books
that you've loved.
So with a book like
"Mistress of Spices," which
was made into a movie, I
set myself the challenge
of writing a magical
realist tale, a tale which
is set in the real world,
here in the Bay Area,
but has magical elements.
So the main character,
Tilo, she has the power--
she works in an Indian grocery.
And if you walked
into that grocery,
she would have the power
to look into your heart
and know what it is
that you most needed.
And she would take a spice, and
infuse it with special powers,
and give it to you, sometimes
without you knowing it.
So that was one.
Then, in "Palace of
Illusions," the challenge was I
wanted to take an epic-- the
"Mahabharata" in this case,
and retell it from a
woman's point of view
because I felt hearing
it or seeing it
through a woman's
eyes would change
the tale in interesting ways.
So the main speaker over
there is Panchaali, Draupadi,
who tells us the story now
as she is experiencing it.
In this, I wanted
a formal challenge.
So this is a book that
is a novel in stories.
Now, I've written
stories before,
like "Arranged Marriage."
And I've written novels before.
But this one is stories that
all join up to create a novel.
So this was a
different form for me.
But I really like
this form because it
allowed me to move
through, like, three
generations of women's lives
in a very agile manner.
I didn't have to go through
everything in every life.
I could focus on the
important moments,
the moments that
transformed them,
the moments that were
emotionally resonant.
And I could also tell
some of the stories
from the point of
view of men who
are important in their lives.
And these are sometimes
men in their family.
But sometimes,
they are strangers
who come into their lives
and become connected to them
in unusual ways.
So one of the other
themes in this book
is also the question, what
is it that we mean by family?
Is it blood family?
Yes, of course.
But are there other
kinds of families?
Are there ways in
which we connect
to people who become extremely
important, both positively,
sometimes negatively,
in our lives.
So that gives you a little
bit of an idea about the book.
And I'm going to read a
couple of passages to you
from different voices so you
get a sense of, you know,
the characters a little bit.
And then I'll be happy to
take some easy questions.
[LAUGHTER]
Right.
The first passage I'm
going to read to you
is in Sabitri's voice.
Now, Sabitri grows up in
the generation before mine.
She's kind of my
mother's generation.
And at that time, you
know, obviously, things
are very different for
women who want an education.
And Sabitri really
wants to go to college,
but she is from a small village.
Her family doesn't
have any money.
But her mother begs a
woman who is well off
and who has a home in Kolkata.
She says, you know.
And that woman says, OK.
Your daughter can live in
my house and go to college.
But in that house, Sabitri's
not very well treated.
Even the servants-- or, I should
say especially the servants
treat her badly because
they're like, you know,
she's like a charity case.
And why is she getting
room and board, and then
she never works like we do?
So she's very unhappy.
She's very lonely.
And she loves the studying part.
But the rest of it is very hard.
And when she's feeling
especially homesick,
she goes up to the
terrace of this building.
And she just looks
up at the sky,
and she thinks about her family.
And, you know, she
just tries to regroup.
And she's always alone
in this old terrace
in the back part of the house.
But one night when
she goes up there,
she meets a young man there.
And that is Rajiv, who
is the son of the house.
He's the only son
of the house, so you
can imagine there's a
lot of pressure on him.
And the two of them
become friends.
And they get to
talking about all
of the pressures in their lives.
And they feel that
they can really
trust each other
with what they say,
and they understand each other.
And they begin to
become very close.
So I will read to you a
little bit from that segment.
"Summer had descended upon
Kolkata with epic vengeance."
Oh, sorry.
I'll read you a little
bit before then.
This is when they're
getting to be friends.
"Days passed.
How many?
It is hard to keep
of such mundanities
when one is balanced
inside a fairy tale.
After some time, he brought
up an old, red quilt
so they could sit in
comfort as they spoke.
One moonless night,
he laid down on it
so he could point out the
constellations to her.
Here is Kalpurush
with his shining.
Here are the seven wise rishis.
She was impressed.
She hadn't thought a city boy
would know the names of stars.
Maybe that was what made
her lie down next to him
on the worn malmal, though
her mother's warnings buzzed
in her ears like mosquitoes.
She told him her dreams.
She would dress
in a starched sari
and teach history
to school children,
stories of conquerors
and despots.
Her students would be obedient.
She would never
need to cane anyone.
She would become a principal
with tortoiseshell glasses,
the entire school
standing at attention
when she entered
the assembly hall.
He nodded.
She would make a
great principal,
he said with conviction.
He wound a finger
softly around a lock
of her hair, which he had
persuaded her to unbraid.
That was what made her
fall in love, finally--
his belief in her
and his gentleness.
But even as she confessed her
dreams, they were changing."
And you might imagine what
her dreams are becoming,
that they're falling in
love, and maybe something
will come out of it.
Because at this time, the
lady of the house, Leelamoyi,
has become very fond of her
suddenly because Sabitri's
a very good cook.
And one day, she made a
dessert that all of her guests
just loved.
And now, she has Sabitri making
desserts for her all the time.
And she's given her gifts.
She's given her saris.
So Sabitri's like,
well, maybe this
is going the way
I want it to go.
But then--
"Summer had descended upon
Kolkata with epic vengeance.
Sabitri came back from
college bedraggled with sweat,
craving a bath,
cold water cascading
over her body in
the maid's bathroom.
But a servant was waiting.
Leelamoyi wanted to see her.
Sabitri was surprised.
Let me drink some water,
she said, change my sari.
The woman scrunched up her
face and shook her head.
Rani Ma's waiting.
Better come right now.
The first thing she
saw when she entered
the room was the red
quilt from the terrace,
crumpled on the floor like
the pelt of a dead animal."
Right?
So they've been meeting
in secret until now.
"The blood rushed to
her head and then away.
She had to hold on
to the door frame.
When her vision cleared,
she looked around
for Rajiv, who would defend her.
But there was only
Leelamoyi, and behind her,
Paro, her special maid,
hands on her hips,
swollen with satisfaction.
From across the years,
Sabitri remembers
Leelamoyi's contorted mouth
spitting out invectives--
conniving slut, harlot's
daughter, poisonous
snake in my bosom.
Her own mouth was
frozen, so that when
she tried to say she
had done nothing wrong,
the words would not obey.
She learned that Rajiv had
been sent away already,
to his uncle's house
in another city.
He would continue
his studies there.
So don't be thinking that
you can sink your witch
claws into him again.
As for Sabitri, she was to
leave the house right now.
No.
Leelamoyi didn't care where she
went or what happened to her.
Sabitri stood at the
tram stop for a long time
in the oppressive dusk, carrying
her small painted trunk.
Finally, she boarded a
tram that would take her
to the men's college where she
went for her math and science
classes.
She could think
of no other place.
She opened her
handbag, so light,
and looked down at the
frighteningly few rupee notes
in there.
Her trunk was light, too.
Paro had followed
her to her room
and rummaged through it-- let's
see what you're stealing--
and taken the silk saris.
She'd taken some of
Sabitri's own things,
as well-- a buffalo horn comb
that her mother had given her,
a tiny bottle of
rose water Sabitri
had saved up for months to buy.
Sabitri had been too
heartsick to protest.
The men's college loomed
eerily in the gloom.
She slipped through
the gate, thankful
that the gate man wasn't
there to stop her,
and ran up the stairs.
On the second story, at
the end of a corridor,
there was a small
room with a plaque
on it-- women's common room.
She had gone there once,
exploring with her friends.
It was piled with
dusty furniture
and smelled of mice droppings.
But there was a bolt on the
inside and a small toilet.
She could stay
there for the night.
Tomorrow-- she couldn't handle
the thought of tomorrow yet.
When she reached it, the door to
the common room was padlocked.
The strength went out of her,
and she slid to the floor,
unable to hold in
her sobs any longer.
Terror and rage, but
foremost was the fear
of what might happen
to her tonight
when the night watchman came by.
Would he throw her
out on the street?
Would he do worse?
Beneath it all roiled
the humiliation.
What would her parents,
her relatives, her village
say if they knew she had been
kicked out of the Mittir home
like a dog?
No one would care that
the love she and Rajiv had
felt for each other
was pure and beautiful.
She had been weeping too
hard to hear the footsteps.
When she felt a hand
on her shoulder,
she flinched and cried
out, throwing up her arms
to protect herself."
And I'm going to stop
this passage here.
Yes, very wickedly,
I'm going to stop here.
And I'm going to
move on to Tara.
So we move across
two generations
and across the world.
Tara's living, at this
time, in Houston, Texas,
which is where I now live.
And now I've lived in
Houston long enough
that I feel comfortable setting
parts of my books in Houston.
And Tara has been having
an interesting life.
She is now, for some
important reasons, estranged
from her mother and her father.
She's kind of cut herself off
from the Indian community.
She's dropped out of school.
She works part-time
in a thrift shop.
And she's just moved in, a few
months before this, with a man
she met.
And he is a massage therapist.
OK, so that's her background.
I'll give you just
a little bit where
she's trying to figure out why
she likes this man so much,
just a tiny bit.
"I love Robert's hands.
I've loved them ever since he
ran them over my naked back
at our very first meeting.
This is not as
risque as it sounds.
I was at Body Work for
the weekday half-hour
special, which my friend
Blanca had bought me
as a birthday gift.
He gave me a full hour, and
then invited me to dinner.
Over souvlaki and
ouzo, we discovered
that we shared a passion
for sci-fi movies.
A month later, he asked
if I'd move in with him.
I knew it was too soon.
Plus, I'd never
lived with a man.
Yes, I said.
Oh, yes."
All right.
But, as I'm sure her
mother would have told her
if she had asked, there are now
problems, and they're fighting.
And this is about
why they're fighting.
Now, I should
preface-- I think this
is a funny part of the book.
So, you know, I'm just telling
you because sometimes people
feel, you know,
literary readings,
everyone has to be
intellectual and serious.
But feel free to laugh.
In fact, I'll cue
you by raising my--
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
"The reason for my fight with
Robert is a stuffed raccoon.
He won it from Victor,
his best buddy,
the result of a pool-playing
bet involving something called
a bank shot with
throw, the intricacies
of which I failed to grasp.
He installed it on our chest
of drawers two weeks ago.
Apparently, the
raccoon is valuable.
More important, Victor had
shot and stuffed it himself,
and he was terribly cut up
at having to part with it.
He'd offered to buy it
back from Robert for $200.
And you refused?
I eyed the creature
with disbelief.
Its upper lip was
lifted in a snarl,
and one front leg was
shorter than the other,
though that could have been a
result of Victor's taxidermy.
It appeared ready to spring
off the chest of drawers
and launch itself upon us.
Well, naturally, said
the love of my life.
You should have
seen Victor's face.
He ran his hand over
the raccoon's back.
Feel the fur.
It's incredible, soft and
bristly at the same time.
I declined.
The only thing I
found incredible
was that he expected me
to sleep in the same room
with this monstrosity.
Want a shower, Robert
offered as a peace gift.
I considered sulking,
but I love showering
with Robert, his fingers
unbuttoning my clothes,
letting them drop
where they will,
the way he holds me as he
soaps my back, as though I
were a child who
might slip and fall.
But afterwards,
I couldn't sleep.
I became aware of a musky odor.
The raccoon?
Surely it couldn't
smell, except of whatever
embalment Victor had used.
Was it the scent
of another woman?
I couldn't stop
myself from imagining
Robert at work, his hands
caressing female curves.
What did he say to them?
What made him the most popular
massage therapist at Body Work?
In the morning, I asked Robert
to please move the raccoon
to the living room.
He refused.
I claimed he was inconsiderate.
He accused me of not
caring about what
was important to him.
I took to covering the
raccoon with a pillowcase when
Robert was out of the house.
He took to checking on it
first thing when he returned.
Without a word, he'd
ball up the pillowcase
and throw it with
vicious accuracy
into our dirty laundry basket.
I'd rescue it surreptitiously
so I could use it again.
It was like a vaudeville
show, except not funny."
And the thing about
this raccoon is
when I started
writing this story,
I had no intentions
for a stuffed raccoon
to show up and become
an important character,
as this raccoon will be.
This raccoon will, you
know-- what shall I say?--
shape parts of the story.
But that's what
happens sometimes.
You have certain plans
for your stories,
and then the stories
just begin to grow.
And the characters
begin to do things
that you didn't
think they would.
And that's part of
the magic of writing.
When that happens,
I'm like, wow.
You know?
Where's all this coming from?
But thank you so much.
And now for those
easy questions.
Praise is also acceptable.
AUDIENCE: What's the story about
your sari matching the book
rover.
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: Right.
As you noticed, the sari
and the book cover match.
And it's really a very
wonderful, serendipitous story.
So we moved to Houston
about 14 years back.
And there is a
beautiful Indian temple
in Houston, the
Meenakshi Temple.
And my husband, Murthy,
in the audience today,
went to the temple.
And they had offered some
saris to the goddess.
And if you made a donation, you
could get one of those saris.
So he picked out
this sari for me.
Must have been at least
12 years back, right?
And then I put it in my closet.
I wore it a few times.
It's special.
It comes from the goddess.
And then, you know,
I forgot about it.
And then the publisher
decided to create a cover.
And they sent me this cover.
I had nothing to do
with this cover, right?
But I liked it.
I said, I like this cover.
All right.
So here's the cover.
The sari's in my closet.
I'm a little slow sometimes.
I don't make the connection.
But about a week before my tour,
I'm looking through my closet.
What shall I take?
What shall I wear
to my readings?
And I come across this sari.
And it's exactly the same.
And this book is titled
"Before we Visit the Goddess."
And that story in this
book is about Tara
going-- very unwillingly,
under strange circumstances--
but going to the
same Meenakshi Temple
that I got this sari from.
So it was like the
universe making
a perfect, serendipitous cycle.
So now this has become my
book tour sari for those book.
And I also found out--
so the very first time
I wore it for book tour, someone
came up to me later and said,
do you know this has
a name, this color?
And I said, I only
know the English name.
It's some kind of blue.
It's teal in English.
And she says, in
Indian languages,
it's called anandi, which
may be a name you've heard.
And anandi, ananda means joy.
So I felt this was very
joyful, and it was a blessing.
That's my sari story.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that the current novel is
about exploring female success.
And here in Silicon
Valley, we're
surrounded by "Lean In"
and various philosophies
on female success.
What's your take?
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: What's
my take on female success?
That is a very tough question.
But that's a very good question
because it is something
that the women here are asking.
And I think-- I really
think, each woman,
it's very important for us to
create the answer ourselves
and not look to other people.
I think there are
wonderful books out there.
There are wonderful role models.
But ultimately, we have to
decide that for ourselves.
So for me, success means
that I'm doing something good
in the world.
I'm changing the world, in
whatever small way I can,
for the better, and
not doing the opposite,
not changing it for the worse.
So as a writer, my
hope is that my books
will go out into the
world and do something
for increasing understanding
between human beings.
Sometimes it's people
within my community.
Sometimes it's people of other
communities, other backgrounds.
Because one of the
wonderful things of America
is how multicultural we are.
And I think it's
so important for us
to understand each other.
And books are wonderful
way to do that.
I also think success means that
I live according to my values.
If I fall away from
my values, I could
be so successful in
the outside world.
But in here, I failed.
And I guess those
are the two things.
And three, number three--
I want my children
to look back and think,
oh, Mom was special.
I think that would make
me feel successful.
AUDIENCE: So
congratulations on the book.
It's an amazing book.
When I finished
it two nights ago,
my husband was still awake.
And I said, I think I
read a pretty good book.
I don't say that often.
I take a few days to tell
somebody about a book.
And then somehow,
my daughter woke up
in the middle of the night.
And I put her back
to bed, came back.
My husband was still up.
And he's like, you still
think it was a good book?
And I said, it was
a pretty good book.
And by the morning,
it had become--
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: Thank you.
That's a great compliment.
AUDIENCE: By the morning it
had become, it's a great book.
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I reflected
a bit on the book.
And here was one of my
interpretations of it.
And I'm curious to know if
this thought crossed your mind
while you were writing.
We haven't changed a
lot from our ancestors
over the past many decades.
We don't look different.
We don't do different things.
We're just more
dependant on technology.
Very minute changes have
come into our evolution.
So I think the modern-day
definition of evolution
has to do something with a
message in your book, which
I interpreted as-- you take
your ancestors and your elders.
You evaluate their life.
You reflect on it.
And you take their shortcomings,
and you take the successes.
You imbibe their successes.
And then you reflect
on their shortcomings,
and become better at that.
And if you evaluate
your life in terms of,
did I become better in
temperament and in spirit
than my ancestors,
then I have evolved.
And that was one lesson that
I took from the book, where--
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: I
think that's great.
That's wonderful.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm glad it resonated.
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: I think
that resonates with what
I was trying to do in the book.
AUDIENCE: It comes
across crystal clear.
Thanks.
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: Thank you.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: One more comment
on your male characters.
The female characters
are very strong.
They've always been,
in all your books.
I enjoy that.
But at the end of it,
I felt like almost
every male character in
the book was not strong.
And not in a negative sense,
but if I balance it out, I just
feel, are they on purpose weak?
Or is that a truth, that
when you have a strong woman
in the household, it's backed
by not-so-very-strong men?
I don't know if that-- when
you define your characters,
did that cross your mind?
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: No.
Actually, when I was looking
at the men, of course,
the bulk of the spotlight
is on the women.
And that's how it is
in most of my stories.
I think it's really
important for me
to place the women in
the center of my story.
But actually, in this
book, I think the men
play a very important role.
And they are all strong in
their own way, differently.
OK?
So there is Bipin Bihari, who
is the manager of the store
that Sabitri finally
manages to set up.
She has a wonderful, very
successful sweet shop.
But he is kind of the power,
the wind beneath her wings.
And if it wasn't for his
loyalty over decades,
she couldn't have done it.
So yes, he's in a
supportive role.
But he's very strong in himself.
And he has a very
special love for her,
though she's almost
unaware of it.
So I think his life is
very poignant in that way.
So it's a different kind.
It's a quiet strength.
OK?
Sabitri, though, is the one
who will come into the store.
She will bang the pots and pans.
She'll say, what
are you guys doing?
She'll say, I have to
create a new sweet now.
But he's the one who's back
there always supporting.
So that's the kind of supportive
role that some of the men play.
And not always
supportive-- some of them,
there's some betrayal
roles that the men take on.
But there are also
some roles where
the men are transformative.
In the title story, Tara's in
a very bad place in her life.
And she's going to meet
this man just one day.
But there'll be
something he'll say,
and that's going
to change her life.
So that's the kind of
role that I saw men play.
It's a symbiosis in some ways.
It's a symphony of voices.
But perhaps a little bit
extra love goes to the women.
AUDIENCE: Hi, there,
Miss Banerjee.
Thank you so much
for being here.
I've been-- I haven't
read this book yet,
but I've been reading
your books for decades.
And I remember when--
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I grew up in the Easy Bay, and I
remember when my mom first gave
me the "Sister of My Heart."
And she said, this
is a local author.
And it got me really interested
in different cultures.
And it was just a
wonderful, wonderful book.
So thank you for being
such a wonderful influence.
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: And
thank you because that
is my hope with my
books, that they
will reach many
different kinds of people
and pull them into
the world of the book.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so thank you.
I have a couple questions.
I also really love how you have
such strong female characters
in your books.
So I'm curious to know who
are the women in your life
that inspire you for these
characters that you draw from?
And another-- maybe this
is the easier question.
It's so hard not to just want
to eat through the entire books
while reading them because
your descriptions of food
are so, just, incredible.
I'm just craving Indian
cuisine the entire time.
So how do you write such
amazing things about the food?
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: OK.
All right.
I'll answer the
food question first,
and then I'll have you
repeat the other questions
and I'll answer it because
that's a more serious question.
Yes.
I think all these local Indian
restaurants should start
giving me, like, commission.
[LAUGHTER]
But, you know, food has always
been important in my life.
Definitely, I love well-cooked,
well-presented, beautiful food
because so much of culture
is passed on through food.
But for me, especially
as an immigrant woman--
and perhaps for many of
you living in a place
away from where your original
home is-- the food that
is of our childhood,
is of our culture,
is something we carry with us.
It gives us a lot of comfort.
It gives us resonance.
It brings memories with us.
So food is truly a cultural
construct, and especially
for immigrants.
For us, you know, food was
one of the few things we
could carry with us, as it were,
and bring into our new lives.
And so it became
a very tactile way
of carrying our culture
with us, but also
of passing it on to
the next generation.
And along with
those foods, we pass
on certain lessons,
some ways of looking
at life, ways of seeing things.
So that's why food is
really important just
on the level of
ideas in my book.
But this book particularly
is all around food
because a lot of what the
women consider success
is built around food, right?
Durga Sweets is the business
that Sabitri builds,
and that helps her
become successful.
It's all around food.
And she creates sweets, so
it's about creativity, as well.
Bela will take a
whole different path.
She'll be at loggerheads
with her mother
about what food is
really important.
But she will at some point
experiment with fusion cuisine.
She'll create a blog.
And Tara will have a whole
other relationship with food.
She is not a bad cook.
But her motto is kind
of like mine, which
is, from cutting board to
dining table, 20 minutes flat.
And some of this seeps into
my life because on my website,
I have a blog where I
put up food entries,
things that I've-- mostly
things that I've made easy,
original Indian recipes
that I've made easy,
20 minutes flat,
that kind of thing.
So food has always
been important.
For me as a reader, too,
I love reading about food
because it involves our senses.
And I think whenever we can
involve our senses in writing,
we pull the readers right in.
And I like to do that.
And now tell me your
second question.
AUDIENCE: Oh, the
second question--
I'm just curious
to know where you
draw your inspiration from for
such strong female characters.
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: Yes.
Well, you know, my own mother
has been and continues,
even though she's
not alive-- and I'm
sure you feel that, if any of
your parents or grandparents
have passed away.
The influence continues, right?
So she's been an inspiration.
I was very blessed when I
went to college in Kolkata
that I volunteered
with Mother Teresa.
And she was a true
inspiration for me.
She was so giving.
She was so loving.
She did, very quietly, so
much for people around her.
So she was an inspiration.
But actually, my characters
come from the imagination.
And I have to do this.
I have to imagine my characters.
Maybe I'll take just a
little kernel from real life.
But I really have to go
into the imaginary realm.
Otherwise, I don't
have the freedom
to make them do what they
need to do, sometimes
bad things, bad decisions.
However-- this is just
a secret between you
and me-- I never tell my
family and friends this.
Instead, I tell them, you
better be good to me, or else--
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
Or else.
AUDIENCE: So I wore teal
today entirely on purpose,
as you can see.
There are few
questions on the Dory.
Whoever is running,
them, you could probably
check there, as well.
And since I'm here in person,
I'll ask my question directly.
There's a lot of talk about
unconscious bias, right?
And I wanted to ask you,
what should straight men
like myself do in order to
make sure we don't introduce
unconscious bias and
become roadblocks
in the success of women, or even
people who identify themselves
with other gender identities.
What would your advice be
for men in general, I guess?
Yeah.
So unconscious bias
is-- so full disclosure.
I'm a big fan of Sheryl
Sandberg, as well,
my ex-employer and whatnot.
So she talks about
an example where
in a conference room, if a woman
speaks up and gives an idea,
it just passes over.
Five minutes later, a man
picks up the exact same idea,
says the exact
same words, and oh!
That makes a lot of sense now.
So this is an unconscious bias.
Often, we are not even
aware that we are doing it.
But it just sneaks in.
That's why even in Google's
screening interviews right now,
the names are hidden.
We always refer to two
people as the candidate,
and we don't see him or
her, stuff like that.
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI:
Very interesting.
AUDIENCE: So what would be
your take on the whole thing,
I guess?
Or the advice for
people like me.
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: I think
that's a great question.
It's a complex question.
I'm not sure I have
the definitive answer.
But I think for-- and I've been
at the receiving end of that.
I mean, in meetings, exactly the
same thing has happened to me.
So I'm very aware of that.
I think the first thing
is to become aware of it.
And certainly, like what
you're doing, becoming aware
of it is step one.
Right?
I think along with
becoming aware
of it, when you see
others who are not
aware of it, we have
to be able to speak up,
not in some kind of
confrontational way,
but just pointing out, look.
Look, this is what you just did.
This is what you just said.
So I think a lot
of times-- I mean,
unless it's proved otherwise,
I always start from the premise
that this person doesn't
necessarily intend ill
but is just not aware
of what's going on.
Or it's been conditioned so
into him or sometimes her.
I mean, women do this, as well.
So they're not aware
of what they're doing
or what they're saying or how
they're putting someone down.
So I think the first thing is
to make people aware of that.
And that's like the
Band-Aid, right?
But I think one of the things
that's really important to me
is to start with younger
people, with children,
because their minds
haven't become closed
in that kind of way.
So if we start with
children, introducing them
to positive ideas about women or
about people who are maybe not
straight, the gay people,
or whatever, wherever
the prejudice are, people of
another community, communities
of color.
We put stereotypes into
the heads of children.
They don't come
with any of that.
So instead, if we can start
putting positive things.
And a great thing to
do is to introduce them
to all these ideas
through literature
because literature is a
wonderful and non-threatening
and inviting way
of bringing people
into worlds and experiences
they don't know.
And that begins to
change people's minds.
And so I think reading
multicultural books
with children is very important.
Discussing these issues
with them is very important.
And in the adult world,
speaking up against it
when we see prejudice of
this kind is very important.
I always try to put some of
those ideas into my books.
One of the reasons I want
to show strong women--
not perfect women, women
who are just human.
They have positives and
negatives, but they're strong.
And I want people to understand
where they're coming from.
And I want people
to be compassionate
towards their problems.
And my hope is that as
people read these books,
their minds will begin
to change in some ways.
And therefore, I'm really
pleased to see the men
in the audience
because a lot of women
will naturally gravitate
to the thinking.
But it's always very special
for me when men read the books,
and they say, oh, you
know, I really related
to that woman character.
I can understand her.
Empathy is at the heart
of human experience.
Empathy is at the
heart of human success.
If we can't be empathetic,
everything else
we do, you know, it just
falls by the roadside.
So that's a great question.
AUDIENCE: There's a
question on the Dory
that I want to
bring to attention.
And yours is on the Dory, so
you've already answered that.
But of them is, how did you
get started as an author
and what motivates
you to keep writing?
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: How did
I get started as an author
and what motivates
me to keep writing?
Now, you know, I kind
of fell into writing
in a strange manner.
When I was growing
up in India, I never
thought I would become
a writer and really
didn't write anything.
I never thought I had a story
worth telling that people would
be interested in because I
was so immersed in my culture,
I felt, everyone's
life is just like mine.
So it was years after I came to
the US that I became a writer.
And I really think immigration
made me into a writer
for two reasons.
The one thing is when I
was in my home culture,
I didn't think about it.
It was just there.
It was when I came
to America, I began
to see my Indian culture,
really, for what it was,
and I began to see what
I appreciated and missed
about it.
And I began to have some
questions about things
like women's roles and so
forth in Indian culture.
And it wasn't around me.
I missed it.
So I wanted to write
about it, to recreate it
through books--
stories at that time.
I didn't know that I
was going to be any good
or if I was going
to publish anything.
I just wrote to
understand for myself.
I think that's really important.
And I wrote to
understand not just
India but what I was
seeing around me,
other immigrants like myself.
And immigration was such
an amazing experience.
It was at once
transformative and terrifying
because it was the first
I was living on my own
away from my family.
I was living in a culture where
all the rules seemed different.
So, you know, I wanted to figure
things out through writing.
And I could see other
people around me
were going through the
same kind of experience.
And that's how I became a
writer, very tentatively.
For years, I was
a closet writer.
Nobody knew I was writing.
I would be teaching
during the day.
Late at night, I would
sit at my desk and write.
And just a-- I
should share this.
Don't tell other people.
When I started,
I was really bad.
I wasn't good.
But I got better.
And that's the amazing thing
about writing-- and any art,
I think.
If you are sincerely dedicated
to it, and you keep writing,
and you listen, you get
good feedback from people,
and you listen, and you
try to get better, you do.
That was certainly
the case with--
AUDIENCE: My question is related
to how we define success,
and especially for women.
And I'm an immigrant like you.
And I grew up-- and my mom
didn't get to go to college.
And we were three daughters.
And she said, I want you
guys all to go to college.
So my image of who I
would be was always
about having a career.
So I got [INAUDIBLE], came
to America, got married,
and somewhere along, I
became a mother, too.
And to me-- and at
some point in my life,
I had to decide to quit work.
So then it was the
hardest decision for me
because whatever image
I had of me as defined
as success did not involve
staying home and raising kids
because that's what
my grandmother did.
Somehow, I had this message
given to me, not through words.
All that my mom said was, I
want you to have education.
I want you to be independent.
Whatever.
But somehow, I translated
it to being a homemaker
meant it was not success.
But somehow, I did stay
home, raise my kids,
then now, I'm back at Google.
And I have a daughter
who's 22 years old now.
And so I've been telling
a lot of things to her,
same way my mom told me.
And there will be
times in her life
she'll be making
decisions which it's not
the exact words I said to her,
but how she understood it.
And not only that, in my
own life, as you said,
the definition of
success has changed.
And we take on different
roles, and different roles
needs different levels
of contribution.
And the success
definition changes.
And we get messages
from the media
and the peer group
and everything else,
in addition to what
you heard from home.
And I agree with your principals
about being true to yourself.
And sometimes, what
you heard growing up
and thinking what is success
could be in contradiction
with what you feel as
your own value system.
And then the conflict--
and so I just
want you to shed some light,
because it's a topic that's
interesting to me.
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: Yes.
That's a great topic.
And, you know, it's not like
I have all the answers here,
folks.
I just write books in
which people are always
messing up their lives.
But I think we just do the
best with the intentions
that we have at that point,
with the information we have
at that point, and with
the amount of maturity
we have at that point.
And so one of the
lessons that the women
in "Before We Visit the
Goddess," they have to learn--
and it's a lesson, I
think, I have to learn
and I hope I'm
learning-- is just
as we forgive other people,
we have to forgive ourselves.
We have to forgive
our ancestors.
They passed on the best message
they knew how to pass on.
Right?
And we received it the best
way we knew how to receive it.
The intention was always good.
The intention was never bad.
The intention was loving.
And so we did the best we could.
And if it didn't, and
if it wasn't, now I
look back-- and
believe me, I look back
on some of my earlier
decisions, and I'm like, oh.
But, you know, I have
compassion for the person
I was at that point.
That person did
the best she could.
So I think it's important
to find a balance.
We want to be
thinking individuals.
I mean, we don't want to
dwell too much upon things
that we are doing because
we're always making mistakes.
Fortunately I think
our children are
smarter than we give
them credit for,
and they will turn
out just fine.
In spite of all the mistakes
I made in parenting,
I have hope that my children
will turn out just fine.
AUDIENCE: The reason I asked
about unconscious bias was
I think I've been subject
to unconscious bias.
But I've also been the one
who caused unconscious bias.
And I'm going to
share the story, then,
very quickly because I don't
want to take away from you.
But I think we'd be lying if we
think we're the only ones who
are subject to it.
So I've had a boss
here at Google.
She was there,
took google public.
She's left Google since then,
takes all companies public.
I met her for dinner once.
And I said, oh, yeah,
how's Lauren doing.
She said, yeah, her second
birthday's coming up,
but I have no idea.
David's organizing
the birthday parties.
I don't even know anything
about [INAUDIBLE].
In my mind, I did
say, really, Mona?
Like, you have no idea
about your daughter's
second birthday, and
your husband's doing it?
I walked away thinking, I'm
all about women empowerment.
I teach the stretch
classes here.
I council a lot of
women outside Google.
And I was thinking, this is me,
the thing I'm fighting against.
A lot of times, when we talk
about unconscious bias--
and that's why I asked you
that question-- is we're
doing a lot of this to ourselves
and to the women around us.
So I just thought I'd
share that because
of the whole thing
about intention
and being aware
of what things we
are doing so we are
fighting against ourselves.
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: Yes.
I think that's so important.
But just the fact that
you became aware of that,
that's a huge growth step.
That's a huge growth step.
And, you know, that's why we
have a prayer in our language,
in Sanskrit, that I say often.
And I say, oh, Lord, forgive me
for the bad things I've done,
some of which I've known, and
a lot of which I don't even
know that I did it.
So just please help me
become a better person.
Because we don't
become aware of it.
Becoming aware is the first and
perhaps the most important step
towards change.
So I commend you for
sharing that story.
AUDIENCE: The thread that
I'm noticing all the way
through our discussion
and your responses
is that compassion is the
kernel to every woman's success.
And in addition to that--
compassion for yourself,
compassion to not begrudge
yourself because often,
the male definition of
success is very different.
It doesn't require if
you need to balance
being a mother versus being
a father, necessarily.
There are different sacrifices
with being a mother.
Your body's taken
over for 10 months.
There's certain things
that are inevitable.
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: Yes.
And the body continues,
like, many months afterwards.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's all downhill after
that in many ways,
but also very uphill
in other ways.
But it strikes me that
female compassion is not--
it's possible only when you have
compassion towards yourself,
but also only when you have
a compassionate partner that
enables you and encourages you.
And that's something
common, also,
to more Western or
less-- more Western
ideas of what female
success is, too.
You know, Sheryl
Sandberg also says
that you pick a partner
who lets you lean in
or helps you lean in.
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI: Right.
And to that, I think
those are very good ideas
and very important points.
And to that I will say,
that is the ideal situation.
And then I'll say, you
know, a lot of times,
the situation isn't ideal.
What are we going to do?
We're going to do
the best we can.
But if I don't have such a
partner, I'm not going to stop.
I'm just going to
do the best I can.
I mean, I'm blessed.
I do have a partner like
that who is very supportive.
But if I didn't, I shouldn't
make myself stop short.
I shouldn't shortchange myself
because the people around me
are not going to support me.
I'm going to say-- Tagore has
this wonderful song, "Ekla
Chalo Re."
It means, walk by yourself,
forward by yourself.
Hopefully, people
will be there to help.
But ultimately, it's me.
AUDIENCE: It's your journey.
CHITRA DIVAKARUNI:
It's my journey.
And I really can't blame other
people for whatever happens.
I understand, yes, some people
help, some people don't.
But ultimately, I
believe it's my journey.
And it's not even how
much I achieve outside,
but it's my journey in terms
of my attitude inside, right?
Nobody else affects my attitude.
You know, I read
this some time back,
and it's really stuck with me--
we sometimes say, so and so
made me unhappy.
So and so made me unsuccessful.
So and so did-- no, no, no.
I'm the one who
makes myself unhappy.
And any time I think otherwise,
I'm thinking wrongly.
I'm just passing the buck.
And I think that's the
greatest success, right?
Realizing that I'm the
one who makes it happen.
That's success.
And there's a
moment when Sabitri
realizes that in her life.
She's thinking about what is
the happiest moment in her life?
And I won't give it away.
But it's a moment that
deals with herself, not
with the people around her.
In fact, as long as Sabitri's
waiting for happiness
to happen because of some
external relationship,
it slips away from her.
And I think it slips
away from all of us, too.
[APPLAUSE]